ich hatte schon ganz lange vorn hotels
zu testen seit dem ich selber mit der
arbeit hier und da mal hotels getestet
habe habe ich schon gesehen was am
untersten ende möglich ist aber auch was
vielleicht am obersten ende möglich ist
und genau deswegen ist mir heute das
günstigste was ist das teuerste hotel in
komplett deutschland ich bin sprachlos
und wasserschaden das ist schon
tatsächlich ein bisschen es ist mir
wirklich so kann unangenehm preis
leistungsmäßig komplett stupid
in den letzten jahren immer wieder viele
videos von anderen englischsprachigen
youtube angesehen die genau sowas
gemacht haben letzte woche hat celtics
ein video über das schlechteste teil in
köln gemacht wenn ihr das sehen wollen
liegt in der video beschreibung aber ich
hab euch das hier verlinkt ich habe eine
super lange liste von ideen schon seit
jahren auf meinem rechner rumliegen
konnte es aber wegen komani machen und
jetzt bin ich doch mit geimpft jetzt
kann ich irgendwie wieder so ein
bisschen reisen und ein paar hotels
testen kurzes update wir probieren in
den nächsten wochen mal zwei videos
hochzuladen donnerstag etwas leichter
content sonntags weiterhin vater content
und es kommt in den nächsten wochen auch
wieder was mit ich habe
also nicht viel spaß und couscous kurs
doppelter content und feind hotel
aufgemacht eine super website am
günstigen hotels und allgemein hotels zu
finden aller ersten hotels angezeigt
werden aber irgendwelche eine person in
vier schlafzimmer wir suchen natürlich
ein hotel wo ich allein ich machen kann
und es startet bei 7 euro sechs euro für
irgendwelche chefzimmer was mich dann
aber gewundert hat ist dass es bei 11
euro losgeht mit dem günstigsten
einzelzimmer in deutschland und hat eine
fantastische bewertung von 815 stellen
so lag ist aber ich komme dann steht
kein bett drin oder erwiesen und in der
nähe von stuttgart gibt es tatsächlich
auch das absolut teuerste hotel in dem
george bush angela merkel und alle
größen der gesamten welt herunter
gekommen sind ich verrate nicht zu viel
aber ein kurzer satz damit er versteht
auf was für einem level dass es zum
erstaunen vieler gäste sind ist jedoch
weniger die vergoldete wasserhähne das
champagner frühstück oder der whirlpool
mit blick über die dächer der altstadt
an den schwindelerregenden preisen ist
vor allem der butler schuld
sieben von zehn also das ist das level
auf dem morgens bei dem teuren und
günstigen
nach fünf stunden fahrt habe ich endlich
geschafft in die stadt in der wir das
günstigste hotel des ganzen landes
finden stuttgart das hotel scheint
mitten in der innenstadt zu sein was
mich ein bisschen wundert weil ich hätte
so ein hotel dieser preisklasse eher in
der nähe vom hauptbahnhof vermutet wo
vielleicht leute auch mal nur für eine
stunde einkehren nichtsdestotrotz bevor
wir reingehen ich habe mir ein paar
kategorien ausgewählt nach denen ich die
hotels bewerten werde einmal zimmer
größe ausstattung und so weiter service
verpflegung sauberkeit und
preis-leistung jetzt reingehen zimmer
begutachten und nicht erwischt werden
beim film
sie will zu gut auf bin ich total wäre
sehr gut also ich habe einen schlüssel
bekommen zehn von zehn bisher die
personen an der rezeption war supernett
super kompetent hat keine scheiße
gelabert war sogar schnell jetzt wenn
ich ehrlich komplett gespannt wie das
zum außen das billigste hotelzimmer
dass die liste hotelzimmer
was zu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin sprachlos ich bin ehrlich
sprachlos direkt eine tour ja es ist
riesengroß ist viel größer als die
letzten hotels in denen ich war wir
haben ein doppelbett aber ich bin
natürlich alleine natürlich sind hier
dass solche sachen würden in einem
teuren hotel nicht passieren aber ich
meine wir haben zehn jahren 90 bezahlt
auch die kureinrichtung würde man sonst
eher weniger sind okay gut der müll ist
nicht geleert wir haben schmutz aber wir
schauen uns erst mal das zimmer grob an
und dann gehen ins detail der mine
doppelbett wer ein sofa wir haben einen
arbeitsbereich mit ok großen fernseher
es wird ein bisschen schwer von da
hinten dann noch irgendwas auf diesen
fernseher zu erkennen bei meinen schrank
das ist natürlich jetzt auch nicht
optimal und wir sind tatsächlich mitten
in der stadt und nicht beim bahnhof also
hier ist keine wirkliche gegend oder so
sondern hier spielt sich tatsächlich
leben ob wir sind restaurants und das
beeindruckt mich wirklich aber das
schlimmste an günstigen hotels sind
vermutlich weder und da schauen wir als
nächstes dran
es ist kein luxus bat um ghana das war
auch an der ausstattung wurde gespart
aber wir haben genug platz und wir haben
ein dach über dem kopf und wenn man
jetzt als jugendlicher als studentin
irgendwo auf reisen ist würde das hier
100 prozentig reichen also jetzt mal
ganz im ernst dass hat zehn euro 91 cent
gehört das ist ein absoluter traum aber
natürlich kann mich auch nicht
unvorbereitet ich habe eine uv-lampe
dabei mit der wir das komplette bad das
komplette zimmer auf alle spuren
untersuchen werden auf den ersten blick
scheint es wirklich ok zu sein aber wie
sieht's auf den zweiten aus
wir starten auf dem bett sieht frisch
gewaschen aus ich sehe hier erst mal
nichts hier können kann ich wirklich gar
nichts erkennen ich habe die lampe aber
schon getestet ich weiß also dass sie
funktioniert hier sehen wir die ersten
zwei stellen hier sehen wir auch noch
irgendwas ich will gar nicht wissen was
das ist auch okay hier sind dann doch
schon einige stellen neu ok
hier haben wir auch etwas
ansonsten ist das aber im großen und
ganzen würde ich sagen okay also sieht
jetzt nicht so aus als könnte man sich
auf gar keinen fall ihren trend legen
aber wie sieht im badhaus ist er
eigentlich ganz okay okay die toilette
gucken wir ganz zum schluss ja hier um
die toilette drum herum sehen wir
natürlich schon die ein oder andere
verschmutzungen hier auch aber es ist
deutlich weniger schlimm als gedacht und
am spiegel an der steckdose auch das ist
ziemlich sauer der badewanne könnte mir
auch vorstellen dass es schrecklich ist
und dass diese sachen einfach
vernachlässigt werden
sie ist nichts die ist gar nichts okay
da oben gab es anscheinend ein
wasserschaden das ist natürlich nicht
gut und jetzt die toilette das ist große
finale
[Musik]
hier sehen wir natürlich einige
verschmutzung ja
das ist schon tatsächlich ein bisschen
nasty aber ganz im ernst hier war auf
jeden fall jemand drin und hat
geburtstag und zwar nicht nur ein
bisschen sondern wirklich gründlich ich
habe keine ahnung wie das gehen soll mit
zehn euro 91 pro nacht aber es
funktioniert
[Musik]
wie gut ist das bett
sein würde ich sagen ist es okay aber
wir haben eben schon gesehen das bett
ist sauber und eine nacht hält man es
hier wirklich aus aber ohne neue welche
bewertung würde ich diesen hotelzimmer
geben das zimmer an für sich ist groß
die lage ist sogar das sind zwei
positive punkte negativ ist aber
definitiv der zustand an einigen stellen
sind sachen kaputt man sieht dass ein
wasserschaden gab der schrank ist
komplett am wackeln und die ausstattung
ist natürlich nicht zehn von zehn bei
preis leistung aber ein einzelner punkt
ist den wir bewerten lassen wir das erst
mal außen vor das zimmer all in all
kriegt von mir eine fünf von zehn ist es
genau in der mitte es geht viel besser
es geht aber auch viel viel schlechter
wir haben platz und alles ist eigentlich
find nächster punkt service können wir
eigentlich recht abkürzen es gibt keinen
services der service den wir unten an
der bedienung hatten war eigentlich ganz
nett war super ist aber auch nicht 24 7
das ist okay aber eher eine drei von
zehn verpflegung fast genauso unnötig
das zu bewerten wie service weil außer
einem snackautomaten indem man ein
bisschen getränke und sneakers und neben
der rezeption kaufen kann ist hier
nichts da aber wir sind mitten in der
stadt wir könnten hier sofort irgendwo
essen gehen deswegen ist es nicht so
schlimm aber die verpflegung ist nur
drei von zehn sauberkeit wahrscheinlich
einer der wichtigsten punkte bei
hotelzimmern hat mich ehrlich komplett
überrascht der müll war nicht leer was
mich ehrlich gewundert hat weil
ansonsten war das zimmer ziemlich sauber
für den zimmern wirklich was sauberkeit
angeht nur sieben von zehn geben weil
ich würde mich hier nicht unwohl fühlen
jetzt duschen zu gehen es ist fein und
der letzte um krasseste punkt bei diesem
zimmer preis leistung das ist kann ich
direkt sagen es ist für mich eine
absolute 10 vom 10 wir haben zehn euro
90 bezahlt ich habe keine ahnung wie
sich das hier rentieren soll ich brauche
bei einem stadthotel einfach nur dass
ein bett ein sauberes bad und das ist
wirklich nur zehn von zehn
durchschnittlich bekommt das zimmer von
mir eine ich weiß nicht den durchschnitt
aus allem was ich gesagt habe wenn ihr
in stuttgart seit und ein zimmer für so
wenig geld braucht dies nur geht dann
kommt ins meer sc 99 das ist absolut
fallen und hätte ich mehr zeit für
dieses video hätte ich hier eine nacht
verbracht und hätte euch dann vernünftig
sagen können wie die gesamte experience
gewesen wäre aber leider habe ich nur
einen tag zeit und deswegen muss ich
mich leider erbarmen jetzt im teuersten
hotel deutschlands in baden baden zu
schlafen wo wir hinfahren
ich bin da
[Musik]
hat meine großen parkplatz der welt ist
so fragen wir mal die tierchen
anschließend das war super und in der
ist
schön dass sie da sind und wenn sie
etwas brauchen rufen sie gerne an
es ist wirklich unglaublich weil das
zimmer sie ziemlich basic aus aber man
sieht und man fühlt und man riecht dass
alles absolut wirklich absolut höchster
standard ist das beste vom besten was
möglich ist man spürt das einfach und
direkt der service wie ich das intro
hier bekommen habe ist natürlich ein
komplett anderes level und das ist das
zimmer
hier kommen wir ins zimmer rein und
schauen direkt hier auf unser riesiges
bett das deutlich deutlich bequemer
aussieht als in dem hotelzimmer nehmen
gerade eben wann wer hätte es gedacht
der linken seite haben eine komplette
riesige schrankwand sich natürlich nicht
brauche wenn ich nur eine nacht da bin
von hier aus geht es weiter und unser
nachtisch und unser bett wir haben hier
direkt an unserem bett alle möglichen
knöpfen alles zu bedienen zu können das
wifi ausmachen und das komplette licht
viele leute haben keinen bock auf
strahlung und keine ahnung was dann kann
man das hier direkt am bett ausmachen
besten gleich über dem bett haben aber
drei bilder die symmetrisch angebracht
sind dass wir einem anderen hotel leider
auch relativ schwer zu finden aber man
sieht schon dass wirklich einfach alles
absolut höchster standard ist also
wirklich top notch vor dem wetter so
eine kleine couch der koffer der
natürlich von dem servicemitarbeiter ins
zimmer gebracht wurde dann hier so ein
paar kleine aufmerksamkeiten vom hotel
eine kaffeemaschine bisschen mehr wasser
ist in meerwasser kleine minibar dann
ein arbeitsbereich regenschirm was mir
auch sehr positiv aufgefallen es ist das
komplette zimmer indirekt beleuchtet ist
also man hat nicht so eine super helle
lampe von der decke das wäre sehr
ungewöhnlich aber es war eben in anderen
hotels und das gefällt einfach positiv
aus das ist wirklich sehr gut
ausgeleuchtet ist fernseher ist jetzt
nicht zehn von zehn aber ist die cent
fernseher und jetzt das bad wunderschön
wirklich alles in so sandstein farben
sehr hochwertige dusche mit reden kommt
wie wärs in motions alles da dann
natürlich so sachen wie hauseigene
bademäntel eigene handtücher ein
absoluter traum und das ist im prinzip
das zimmer bevor wir uns aber jetzt
anschauen wie sauber das zimmer ist wie
gut das personal ist wie gut das essen
schmeckt wir das alles hier ausprobieren
einmal kurz der preis wird nicht
umfallen damit ihr das in relation
stellen könnt zum letzten hotel dieses
zimmer kostet mich für einen 8 600 und
30 das aber jetzt auch mit der
sauberkeit aus dem zehn euro zimmer
mithalten kann das überprüfen wir jetzt
und hier gehen wir richtig ins italien
hier
[Musik]
erster griff enttäuschend mal gucken wie
groß das reinigungspersonal ist
ist natürlich mehr kann auf hohem niveau
aber dieses zimmer kostet 630 euro drei
griffe dreimal staub gefunden ich glaube
ich werde ein test
pack alter ich dachte ehrlich bevor ich
den ersten griff gemacht habe okay in
diesem hotel werde ich nichts und am
bett es auch sehr sauber in den
schränken das ist auch sehr sauber die
sind leuchtet nachts der schweiz ist
natürlich komplett anderes level hier
mit einbauschränken ansonsten ist
natürlich alles top notch von der
sauberkeit zumindest das was ich mit
bloßem auge erkennen lässt und bevor wir
jetzt mit dem uv licht ins detail gehen
bestelle ich als erstes essen ich habe
mich dagegen entschieden im restaurant
zu essen einfach weil ich das essen film
will weil ich vernünftig testen will
deswegen muss ich wohl oder übel leider
aufs zimmer bestellen und wir schauen
jetzt erstmal was es da so alles gibt
knusprig gebratener blumenkohl gewitter
wolfsbarsch tranche vom milchkalb
drücken
ich würde gern essen bestellen ist es
noch möglich knusprig gebratener
blumenkohl okay das nicht möglich vakuum
bürger ist klingt die hauptfächer zu
weswegen ich fatalerweise auf einem
video berger und kleinen salat zur
vorspeise umsteigen musste schauen wir
mal aber ich glaube das sollte das auch
tun ich hatte mich doch schon so auf
meine frittierte wassermelone gericht
aus dass man bei an netzkauf wir starten
beim bett und ich sehe rein gar nichts
wenn das so ein bisschen am leuchten ist
hier dann sind das einfach fusel es nie
irgendwo irgendwas tisch auch komplett
sauber das komplett sauber und jetzt das
große finale das badezimmer
nach hier sehen wir kleine
verunreinigungen
ganz kleine
wir sehen auch so ein bisschen
ansonsten ist das aber natürlich top
notch badewanne ist komplett sauber
sauber so was hier an der wand sehen
wenn bisschen das wieder und jetzt die
absolute königsdisziplin das klo
hier sehen wir überall so ein paar
spritzer bis auf minimale stellen ist
dass zehn von zehn pilger das ist
komplett cars also da muss ich wirklich
sagen das beeindruckt die ich echt weil
egal wie gut das hotel ist das sind die
stellen an denen man verpackt aber hier
ist alles picobello jetzt muss nur noch
das essen stimmen und dann ist es
wirklich eine absolut experience
[Musik]
guten appetit noch
das ist so falsch ist mir wirklich so
krank unangenehm weil halt die ganze
zeit leute kommen die deutlich älter
sind als ich und ich bin am liebsten
jedem von denen sagen würde so ey ich
mache das nur fürs video ich mache das
nicht zu aus privaten gründen aber es
mir schon leicht und angenehm muss ich
sagen das hier ist unser abend es wir
haben zur vorspeise einen gemischten
salat der wunderbar aussieht dann kam es
als beilage und als hauptgericht ein
vakuum
es ist kaum für herzkranke was geht mag
sich worte eine expertenmeinung in die
hauptkirche hatte zu deswegen konnte ich
nur noch diesen einen magier bürger
stellen
[Musik]
ja danke
ich bin fertig mit dem essen der bürger
war sommer acht von zehn der salat war
eine absolute zehn von zehn aber preis
leistungsmäßig komplett stupid das essen
was ich gerade gegessen habe hat 59 euro
gekostet ich würde das muss ich auch
nochmal sagen ich würde so etwas niemals
privat machen ich bin nie privat in
hotels und ich mache das bringt ob nur
fürs video ist natürlich heiß aber ich
mache es nur fürs video jetzt heißt es
schlafen und morgen den rest vom hotel
abdecken
[Musik]
acht uhr morgens ich habe unheimlich gut
geschlafen das zimmer sieht hier
morgenlicht noch mal viel besser aus und
ist ein absoluter traum und ich freue
mich ganz besonders aus frühstück und
auf meinen fertig vollgeladen das auto
ein absoluter sehen
[Musik]
das frühstück war ein absoluter traum
aber eigentlich muss dass jemand
bewerten deutlich mehr ahnung hat als
ich das ambiente war atemberaubend
meinen platz war mitten im garten direkt
an einem brunnen die brötchen waren
frisch und beim service muss ich gar
nicht erst anfangen das personal ist
wirklich auf einem anderen level und die
auswahl bot das omelett war perfekt und
hübsch zubereitet und ein frisch
gepresster orangensaft in kombination
aus lachs day was hast du die scheiße
geschrieben und ein frisch gepresster
orangensaft in kombination mit lachs hat
mich vitaminreich und ausgewogen in den
tag starten lassen 9 von 10 punkten und
damit endet meine nacht im brenner's
park hotel in baden baden es war ein
absoluter traum ich habe mehrmals
probiert mit der kamera in den spa
bereich zu gehen weil der spa-bereich
oder diesbar bereiche auch
aushängeschild für das hotel sind aber
da sind tatsächlich gehörte auch die
anderen gäste haben genauso viel oder
wenn nicht sogar mehr für ihre
hotelzimmer bezahlt und wollen
vielleicht nicht von einem 22-jährigen
die youtuber im spa-bereich genervt
werden ich war aber da es war ein
absoluter traum das zählt alles absolut
erst zusammen kommen wir zur bewertung
von brenner's park hotel das zimmer
gross unheimlich hochwertig eingerichtet
und doppelte türen um gegen strahlung
wlan strahlung und sonstwas zu schützen
der stil muss einen gefallen ist ist
alles so ein bisschen älter
traditioneller konventioneller ich mag
dass ich fand's super und es war
trotzdem nicht altbacken einziges
problem der ausblick war nicht das
maximum was möglich gewesen wäre
deswegen zimmer von mir 8 5 von 10
punkten services wo soll ich anfangen
ist war ein absoluter traum bei der
anmeldung im hotel habe ich quasi so
eine museumsführung bekommen halbe
stunde durchs hotel komplett erklärt
bekommen was da abgeht wie das läuft
währenddessen hat es jemand anders darum
gekümmert mein auto zu parken und als
laden zu hängen die leute waren super
professionell aber gleichzeitig
irgendwie nah war persönlich und haben
gesagt okay da kommt jemand der es jung
der muss jetzt nicht auf absolut
perfektem hochdeutsch angelagert werden
sondern deswegen wieder halbwegs normal
mit dem kann man zu sprechen trotzdem
super professionell bisschen distanziert
service zehn von zehn ganz klar
verpflegung leider konnte ich abends die
hauptkirche nicht testen obwohl in
englischen karte stand dass sie
eigentlich noch geöffnet haben müsste
schlecht aber abseits davon wurde
natürlich trotzdem möglich gemacht was
ich noch was essen kann ich habe einen
sehr guten salat gegessen einen guten
burger der aber jetzt nicht überragend
war und leider waren die post alt
deswegen bekommt das essen von mir
siebeneinhalb vom 10 ich hätte mir noch
so mehr hofft frühstücks perfekt da habe
ich gar nichts dran zu meckern
sauberkeit ihr habe es gesehen alle
wichtigen stellen super clean alles
perfekt alles gebügelt alles 1 wenn man
danach gesucht hat hat man auch sachen
gefunden man könnte bei dem preis
erwarten dass es gar nicht gibt deswegen
gibt es dafür punkteabzug aber für mich
hat es wirklich quasi keinen unterschied
gemacht neun von zehn dieser preis
leistung wobei wo fängt man da an ich
habe mein leben lang nur urlaub im
wohnmobil gemacht barney im hotel
deswegen bin ich ziemlich fern davon so
was privat zu machen aber wir tun das
für die wissenschaft für den youtube
kanal und obwohl ich eigentlich
überhaupt kein typischer hotel länger
bin obwohl ich selber nie privat urlaub
in hotels mache habe ich den abend
wirklich sehr genossen von uns normalos
wären wahrscheinlich die allerwenigsten
bereits
735 euro für die nacht mit dem essen
auszugeben aber in irgendeiner welt hat
es sich gelohnt weil es eine erfahrung
war weil ich mein erstes mal war für
mich hat sich diese eine nacht gelohnt
aber es wird natürlich kein dauerzustand
preis-leistung sieben von zehn komplett
unnötig aber irgendwie auch geil es war
mal ein sehr anderes video ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen wenn ja lacht dem
video gern leichter und vergesst nicht
den kanal zu abonnieren damit ihr nicht
verpasst wenn ich in den nächsten wochen
die teuerste suite in ganz deutschland
post- schäkel was ich vermutlich machen
werde freut euch darauf ich freue mich
wenn ich von sam das ist wild lebend
wieder komme und endlich wieder content
machen kann also denkt nicht ich hatte
die letzten drei wochen immer dasselbe
t-shirt an gehabt ich muss nur jetzt
alles fertig machen bevor ich mit fritz
nach schönen fall wir sehen uns j
[Musik]